let me know if you think anything should
be in any other spot in this trailer
order please tell me in the comments it
works really hard on this but if you
think anything should be in any
different spot just comment down below
we are i am a small channel so please
consider subscribing if you're you're
watching this and you're not subscribed
yet i would really appreciate it thank
you so much and enjoy
this is my vow
oh god she will die
[Music]
[Music]
doing guys
said this would be a relaxing holiday i
said it was going to be like a relaxing
holiday
[Music]
classic floor adventure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jane
it's been like three four years eight
years seven months and six days
it's just my first bad guy never forget
you first
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flicked too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually great
say that was very very impressive what
you did back there
[Music]
not like the other guns
you